what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in and the
foreseeable future okay
man I'm excited I've never really done
and just like I've read and justice
before to be honest with you guys like
I'm literally going through this comic
as I'm as I'm going it like literally is
I'm bring it to you guys I'm going
through this comic it's good man dude
it's so good it's so good oh my god okay
so well no I think I may have read the
first chapter because some of this looks
familiar but it's but it's been so long
but in justice the comic series was
based on the video game and it was
literally just designed to give us the
rundown of like you know what happened
with the video game how those things
came to fruition how it all started and
it's super cool because we've got the
we've got injustice two coming up which
I'm I'm hyped I'm not gonna preorder it
for Darkseid hell no but I am really
excited I don't I don't pre-order games
anymore but I'm really excited about
about what's gonna happen with regards
to like the storyline Brainiac is gonna
be in there yes
Supergirl man dude this this game man
this guy's gonna be beast man boy this
game's gonna be badass so um injustice
was written by Tom Taylor and as best I
can tell it took the world by storm but
the way this initially opens up is it
focuses on Superman and Lois Lane and
the way that Tom Taylor does this is
beautiful because Superman and Lois Lane
are like the one-two punch of the
romantic comic-book community I mean
it's the the Man of Steel and the first
lady of comics whenever people think of
coming book relationships it's Superman
and Lois Lane it'll stand the test of
time from now until the end of time and
it's beautiful that Tom Taylor chose
this because man because these get rough
for Lois Lane but
and the other half of this is that we
basically have like married couple stuff
one of the funny things that that that
Superman you know really talks to her
about with the idea you know is is well
really it's kind of him figuring it out
you know he just kind of waits up and he
realizes that like she's pregnant you
know because we have super hearing it's
like here's the second heartbeat and so
like that the first thing he does is
like like we gotta move out of a city
man we can't raise a kid at metropolis
that's crazy talk we gotta move out to
the country and we gotta have a farm and
I'm Superman I'll make sure we have
everything we need you know and it's and
it's so cool because you can imagine a
father doing that like you could imagine
a couple living in the city you know
they live in I don't know Oh downtown
Chicago or something like that you know
and they're just like like hey we're
pregnant you know and the guy or the or
the mom you know it's like we need to
not live in the city like we need to
live out in the suburbs like we got to
go buy a house with a nice piece of land
and it's such a beautiful thing to see
because what this does is it humanizes
Superman we think of him as the Man of
Steel the guy who could do anything you
know the guy that could hold planets and
all that kind of cool stuff and it's
good to see him human because right now
he's just a guy who knows he's gonna be
a dad and he's celebrating the idea of
being a dad now
the kicker to all this is that lois
lane's basically called away you know
with regards to an emergency and in the
results that she essentially just kind
of takes off you know to go do whatever
is if she does you know with regards to
her job at the a-- at the Daily Planet
but from here we switch over to Batman
well the cool thing about this is Batman
is just like he's just kicking some
guy's ass something that that's really
all he's doing well I guess Batman just
beating people up because you know
everybody wants to see Batman be people
I don't about you guys but I read Batman
comedies because like I just want to see
him beat people up but it's cool to see
but the coolest thing about this this is
what I love about this is now his Batman
of Superman I want to be keep in mind is
Batman and Superman are not just two of
the most popular see like the two most
popular superheroes in the history of
comics they have a very long drawn-out
you know history with one another they
fought side by side they've been friends
they've been enemies you know they
fought the same villains together
they're they're founding members of the
Justice League I mean it's it's a great
huge moment of a huge history between
these two guys in addition to this
man's a genius you know and so right off
the bat when Superman shows up he knows
Lois Lane is pregnant because in his
mind it's this idea that Superman is his
not as normal self the way he's purse
parading you know the way is hearts
beating via all these seven things it's
it's basically you know the fact that
that really Bruce Wayne knows that
something is off but the cool thing
about this is that they're sharing a
moment because it's Superman going to
his best friend saying I'm gonna be a
father now the funny thing about this is
like Superman doesn't know the first
thing about being a dad you know I mean
he does to a degree but like no one
knows about how to be a pair you just
have a kid and then you wing it as best
you can and you hope you don't screw up
you know but it's cool because with
these two it's just like you know Bruce
would be there for him like you know if
Superman went to Bruce Wayne said hey
like I really need your help you know he
would be there for you now the kicker to
this is that picking up with Lois Lane
and Jimmy Olsen this is when Tom Taylor
starts to move into the darker
atmosphere this is when Tom Taylor
starts to move into really what the
event that launches the whole injustice
landscape in the first place but what we
have is this idea that there was some
kind of an emergency at the death of
dogs and when Lois Lane and Jimmy Olsen
get there of course Jimmy Olsen is there
to take pictures you know for proof that
Lois Lane is that that should require
but halfway through this we basically
see a gun come out of nowhere and Jimmy
Olsen presumably gets shot and so again
you know while Superman and Batman are
celebrating this Superman goes to Batman
with one of the most really one of the
most honorable request he says I want
you to be The Godfather now this is huge
because this shows that Superman trusts
Batman in an incredible way because what
this means is that if something were to
happen to Superman if he were to pass
away you know or something along those
lines or he were basically called away
from earth that he could never come back
was they like that one story from Batman
Beyond or I guess from from Batman
Beyond his first introduction whether
when the atmosphere was irradiated with
kryptonite and Superman couldn't come
back to earth Bruce Wayne would
basically take over like he would be the
father of Superman's son that's a huge
amount of trust I mean that's an
incredible because it's a lot of faith
in Bruce Wayne and it's really Superman
saying hey I know that if all else fails
I can rely on you to make sure that
those I care about the most are taken
care of now this probably basically
comes to the revelation of the Joker and
it's really just the idea that the Joker
is the one
who was there he's the one that shot
Jimmy Olsen and presumably takes Lois
Lane now the following morning of course
because of the fact that Lois didn't
come back the first thing that you know
that really Superman does is he takes
off to the dock she's like okay we got
to retrace Lois Lane steps we got to
find out where she went to the kick
heard about all this is that we would
expect you know Superman to be able to
pick her or pick up her location
right off the bat I mean rarely I mean
it really it's never happened there's
never really been an instance where
Superman does not know where Lois Lane
is whenever she's in the world if she's
in danger he's there it's a hallmark of
his character he's there in an instant
depending on how fast he can go you know
very you know it depends on the rider
who's riding him sometimes isn't a blink
of an eye sometimes faster than light
the speed of thought it depends on who's
writing the story and what-have-you but
there because of the fact that Lois
Lane's basically vanished just you know
Superman shows up to Batman in really
just freaking out you know now of course
Batman and it's right now in the middle
of working on you know the a bomb that's
basically been taken you know but but
Joker sir I'm sorry uh Superman says
look I can't find her now he's a father
in panic
I mean his wife's pregnant with their
unborn child you know it's really him
fighting for two now and so you know
with Batman he's like you know I have no
idea what's going on you know I I need
to know what you know because he
persistent with the Joker card it says
the Joker has her now of course Batman
being the foremost guy when it comes to
dealing with the Joker I mean it's it's
all hands on deck I mean it's it's
Batman
they looked at Justice League and it's
like Lois Lane's gone missing
no one am no one asks a question no one
says well I mean I'm kind of tied up
right now
no one says well you know I'm kind of
busy right now I'm kind of you know I'm
you know everybody's like were there now
this is cool because it's Tom Taylor
basically saying this is how the Justice
League functions you know it's one thing
if there's a villain that some some
hero's going against you know what the
flash is fighting an enemy and maybe the
flash can handle it maybe he can't maybe
the Justice League will be tied up or
something like that when it's one of
their loved ones when is someone close
to them they're like I'm there and so
they all basically race off to
Metropolis to the scene of the crime and
it's a matter of okay let's see if we
can't find out where she's out of course
you know you got Wally West's cousin
this is Wally West not Barry Allen we
got Wally West here you know racing
Batman around two different locations
and what they basically end up finding
here is that there's this sort of bread
that's been left behind in this sense
that different things have been taken
the bomb there's a kryptonite sample
that's been taken you know the fear
toxin of a scarecrow has been taken with
scarecrow being left for dead you know
by way of the Joker toxin you know and
all these clues all these things lead to
a submarine now of course once once
Superman arrives to the submarine of
course he tears in and he basically
finds what looks like the Joker
you know performing surgery on Lois Lane
but the crazy thing about this is
there's also the fear toxin of scarecrow
and so right off the bat we basically
have doomsday and so it's like as I was
going through this obviously do this
story son like this story man like
Taylor I love you man but it's it's it's
so cool because doomsday we know is like
the most formidable threat of Superman I
mean I would go as far as to say
doomsday is more formidable than
Darkseid
Darkseid's dangerous Darkseid smart but
doomsday always comes back and doomsday
is just a force of nature I mean he just
attacks attacks attacks attacks attacks
just keeps coming and coming and coming
and coming
just again and again and again and again
and it's so cool because
Superman's immediate response is I got
to get him out of here now while this
happens Joker's like let's go it's time
to leave now as soon as he takes off of
course we have you know how Jordan
arriving Wonder Woman the rest of the
Justice League descending on us on his
position now once Batman gets inside the
sub-array this is when he realizes this
is the Scarecrow's fear toxin but he
also starts to put two and two together
with the Joker being here Lois Lane
missing Superman taking taking Darkseid
our life started taking a doomsday into
space
you know the Joker starts taunting
Batman a little bit and says hey man use
your brain surely you can figure out
what's going on here and this is when
Batman comes to the realization you know
he says Superman
that is not doomsday the person you're
taking into space right now is Lois Lane
and this was the most crushing part this
oh my god Rob
when I was going through this I was like
oh my god really like it was I felt I
was it was like the saddest thing I've
ever seen because Superman basically
just killed Lois Lane and while this
happens it's one of the most badass
things The Joker's known for rambling on
the Joker's known for going on about all
these different things stuff like that
he doesn't say that Batman says it's
Lois Superman realizes that her heart
and the heart of her child stop beating
and all the Joker says is boom and the
reason why is because the bomb that
Joker had stolen had been planted in
Metropolis and what he had done is he
had operated on Lois Lane with a trigger
so that when her heart stopped the bomb
would go off now let me tell you
something off corn let me tell you
something the Joker was not prepared man
Superman comes back Superman comes back
like a bat out of hell man he's mad as
hell of course we had Batman like
interrogating the Joker and you know
he's like why you know like why why
would you do something like this you
know and the Joker's like because I
really because I wanted to you know and
his and it's crazy because the Joker
schemes it it was it was said best
during Steve Englehart story the killing
I guess the Laughing fish when Batman
said that Joker's schemes makes sense to
no one but himself you know in addition
to this he was taught he basically tells
Batman every time that you and I fight I
lose I constantly lose you know and so
he was like I thought that I would
basically take out Lois Lane I wanted to
kill someone I wanted to defeat a
superhero and so I figured I'd defeat
Superman by taking away what's most
valuable to him now with Superman coming
back Wonder Woman goes to him
you know and says hey you know I'm sorry
and and Superman has overcome with grief
but here's the problem one he views it
that he was the one that killed him
because he took him into space and of
course you know Wonder Woman says it's
not your fault man it's not your fault
you know you're you
duped into this any was I mean Superman
was tricked into this but this is this
is what's so cool about this stories
because this is Tom Taylor telling us
Superman would go to the edge of the
world for Lois Lane I mean the fact that
he just grabbed doomsday and took him
into space shows that he recognizes how
dangerous doomsday is but it also shows
that he was in a panic I mean sure the
fear toxin had him gripped the fear
toxin was laced with kryptonite which is
what the Joker did with it so that it
would enter the pores of Superman and
make it a susceptible to this in the
first place but it's also this idea that
this is Lois Lane it's not just some
person it's not it's not you know Martha
Kent it's not his mom you know it's not
just some individual out there it's not
Wonder Woman it's Lois Lane man I don't
know how else to say it and so because
of this as a man overcome with grief
he's I mean he's gone in the blink of an
eye now of course Hal Jordan steps up
and says hey man look we need to talk
about this
he encases him you know it says hey we
need to talk Superman says no let me out
I mean he's just like let me out now and
that's the coolest thing about this is
at this moment he's called and that's
what makes Superman so dangerous
Superman is one of these guys where I
would rather fight a Superman who's just
like raging then fight a Superman who's
just gone and it's like I'm going to
kill you right now
it would you would scare that yeah I
mean if Superman was like that if he was
like I'm gonna kill you right now
it's important that you know that like I
would just be like man I mean whatever I
did man sorry like I'm so so sorry like
whatever it happened to be we can I'll
buy you lunch man
like I'm sorry like I would be I'd be
terrified Superman is calm and how
Jordan should have picked up on the
sides Hal Jordans like no I'm not gonna
let you out Superman smashes his
construct and just races off he's gone
in the blink of an eye not only that you
know when Hal Jordan keeps chasing after
him like he literally just takes the
ring from him you know and he was like
now is this not gonna happen you know
and he basically you know he of course
he saves him before he hits the ground
you know but he basically takes away Hal
Jordans ability to communicate with the
rest of the Justice League warning them
as Superman's coming but he effectively
just whisks off to the Gotham City
prison and he doesn't say a word I mean
not a single word is spoken he smashes
into the room with the Joker he pushes
Batman out of the
he grabs a joker and punches a hole in
him and that is the end of that that's
the end of the Joker let me tell you
something Rob core red let me show you
some fanboy this story
man this story's good son I love
injustice it is mad cuz it's such a
great dark take on characters that we
all know and love because you're the DC
Universe can be dark in a lot of
different ways it's really grounded it's
really realistic it's one of the reasons
why I'm really loving DC rebirth of the
moment but in terms of having you know
these heroes their legacy heroes and so
who they are what they stand for is
almost etched in stone that's one of the
reasons why so many people were adverse
to the new 52 Superman who was had a
questionable morality he was trying to
figure himself out there were like good
enough we want the super man that knows
what he stands for he want the Superman
that knows what he's about you know the
like your father Superman it's Joel over
at Cape Joel would say you know they're
like that's the suit man we want because
their personalities are etched in stone
what this does is it takes those and
flips them on their head Superman kills
his own wife because he's tricked into
doing it by the Joker he races to the
other side of the planet and punches a
hole through Joker with metropolis
burning and cinders the only story that
I've really seen that takes a direction
like this is Kingdom Come and it'll be
damned two people that's not one of the
greatest stories I've ever read in my
life hells bells Kingdom Come is amazing
but if you guys are new here two
comments explain make sure you guys hit
the sub button to become part of the Rob
Court and I will catch you all later
peace